i wanted to make another movie with
keira knightley
um
and uh
but i kind of i was scared of it um so i
said i'd only take it on if tom stoppard
wrote the screenplay kind of thinking
that he wouldn't
and that that would get me out of it
but after a period of a couple of months
during which we talked over the ideas
and and our possible approach
uh tom agreed um
uh he then went away and locked himself
in a uh country cottage for six weeks
and wrote the screenplay delivered after
six weeks yeah
and he wrote it all in blue ink by hand
i think tolstoy set out to write a book
about a woman who was kind of depraved
um
that he could hold up as kind of to
condemn
and as he wrote the book it's almost
like the characters um lifted up off the
page in front of him and instead of you
know
condemning her he began to understand
and finally love her
and i think that's what's fascinating
about the book for me and the character
is this kind of ambivalent reaction um
relationship that the novelist had and i
also share
for some time i was very influenced by a
russian
theater director called myhold
who
talks about stylization as being about
the subtraction of surface rather than
decoration you know um
so i was thinking a lot about that stuff
and uh and then i was also you know
going around stately homes in england
and russia looking for locations i
thought one day well if i were to set
this in one location which was the idea
uh what would that location be and um
the theater seemed appropriate given
given the way in which russian society
operated at the time
they
almost seemed to have a kind of identity
crisis they desperately you know they
didn't know whether they were eastern or
western um and and they desperately
wanted to be french to be parisian
really um
and so they they all spoke french um and
to each other and um they wore the
latest paris fashions and they
you know they even had their ballrooms
mirrored so that they could watch their
own performances um as they interacted
so the theater seemed like an
appropriate metaphor on that level
and also on the emotional level for anna
and indeed all the characters the way
the lost uh
tolstoy levin lolstoy um uh turns his
back on on the sort of artifice of
of uh
the society and seeks a more authentic
life and the way
in which anna is kind of playing the
role of being a mother and a and uh and
a wife and it doesn't kind of fit her
well keira i've i've had the kind of
amazing experience of you know she was
18 when we made pride and prejudice
um and i've watched her develop from
uh
stunning ingenue to
to what i believe to be a great great
actress um
uh her
between after atonement she went through
quite a
difficult period i think personally um
not least because of precious intrusion
and so on
and so um and so kind of backed off
quite a lot and did uh some theater and
um and i think
uh
the saying uh if it doesn't kill you or
make you stronger
is true in in kira's case um
she i saw her again after some time and
discovered her to suddenly be far more
empowered than she'd been as a as a
younger woman um
and uh and have this kind of um
uh
devastating honesty in terms of her
femininity um
she's not afraid to um
to play
characters that we might have possibly
have quite an ambivalent reaction to um
we both understood that anna the anna of
that we read in the book wasn't
necessarily a heroine but was a kind of
somewhere between a heroin and an
anti-heroine really
and she embraced that and has an amazing
bravery and boldness